Підвищення зарплат і пенсій,
нові правила отримання субсидій і оплати за комуналку,
а також нововведення для пацієнтів та водіїв.
Новий 2019-й рік
принесе українцям чимало змін, головні - у добірці DW.
Новий рік українці розпочнуть із новою мінімальною зарплатою.
З 1 січня вона зросте до 4173 гривень.
А оскільки пенсії для українців, які мають великий стаж
і старші 65 років, прив’язані до мінімалки,
виплати збільшаться і для них.
Крім того, як обіцяють в уряді, тепер з 1 березня
щороку відбуватиметься автоматичний перахунок пенсій.
Новий рік принесе чимало змін і у сплаті за комунальні послуги.
Зокрема замість "паперових" субсидій надходитимуть
"живі" гроші на банківський рахунок в "Ощадбанку".
З 1 січня на них можуть розраховувати ті,
хто звернеться по допомогу вперше.
Банк розраховуватиметься за платника з надавачами комунальних послуг
та через смс інформуватиме про те,
скільки залишилося доплатити за комуналку.
З 1 травня гроші замість субсидій отримуватимуть і ті,
хто користувався ними вже раніше.
А з 1 жовтня має відбутися перехід на повну монетизацію.
З 1 липня українці матимуть змогу самостійно обирати
провайдера електроенергії: з найнижчими цінами,
відмовившись від послуг монополіста-обленерго.
Крім того, у травні 2019-го
набуде чинності нова редакція закону стосовно послуг ЖКГ,
який передбачає нарахування абонентської плати за комуналку,
апровадження пені та відключення послуг за борги.
Улітку 2019-го в Україні запустять програму "Безкоштовна діагностика".
На обстеження пацієнтів відправлятимуть сімейні лікарі,
терапевти або педіатри - через електронну систему.
Безкоштовно можна буде зробити 12 видів аналізів,
рентген грудної клітини, хребта суглобів, мамографію,
різноманітні УЗД: серця, нирок, судин, молочних залоз,
а також кілька видів біопсії,
ехокардіографію, ендоскопію, нескладні операції
та видалення новоутворень. Важливо, щоб лікарня,
куди звертатиметься пацієнт, а це може бути як приватний,
так і комунальний медзаклад, мала договори
з Національною службою здоров’я,  яка й платитиме за послуги.
У 2019-му році на українських дорогах
має остаточно запрацювати автоматична фото-
та відео-фіксація порушень правил дорожного руху.
Як прогнозують у поліції,
це може статися вже у першій половині нового року.
Також новий рік принесе зміни і для водіїв автівок на єврономерах.
З травня 2019-го "євробляхерів" почнуть штрафувати
за порушення терміну перебування
нерозмитненого автомобіля на території України
Сума покарання варіюватиметься від 170
до 170 тисяч гривень -
залежно від терміну прострочення.
Також за рішенням суду авто можуть забрати.
Наступний рік буде дуже важливим і в політичному житті країни,
адже українці обиратимуть нового президента та парламент.
Від результатів цих виборів залежатиме,
яким курсом далі рухатиметься Україна.